لم يعد السوق الاسبوعي كما كان فحركه
البيع ضعيفه والوجوه حائره بعد ان بلغ
الغلاء مستويات غير مسبوقه
هروبا من غلاء المدينه تحملت الجده فاطمه
عناء التنقل للسوق في ضواحي الرباط بين
انها تفاجات باسعار بعيده عن قدرتها
الشرائيه
31100 ريال
اللحم غالي اللحم اللي واصل 100 درهم واش
يقدر المواطنين
بعد ان كان ارخص الخضروات على الاطلاق
وبلغ سعره نحو دولارين اجمالا فقط تضخم
خلال شهر فبراير الماضي عشره في المئه اما
تضخم المواد الغذائيه فوصل الى 20% لاول
مره في تاريخ المغرب لا تتفق المؤسسات
الرسميه على راي واحد بشان اسباب التضخم
فالحكومه تعتبره مرحليا وترجعه الى عوامل
خارجيه واخرى مناخيه اما الهيئه الساميه
للتخطيط فتقول محلي وتحذر من انه سيصبح
مستداما ندره الماء بسبب تصحيح وهناك
غلاء طاقه وهناك غلاء الاسمده كل هذه
العناصر تكالبت
لتخلوق نوع من الضغط
على الاسعار
ولكبح جماح التضخم تدخل البنك المركزي
برفع سعر الفائده للمره الثالثه على
التوالي بدورها تقول الحكومه ان اجراءاتها
ستمكن من عوده الاسعار الى ما كانت عليه
بدل المنحه
ديال هذه الاسعار ياخذ واحد المنحه
التنازلي وهذا مهم جدا
مهم جدا والحكومه سوف تستمر في العمل بهذا
النفس الجماعي
وبالموازاهه كشفت بياناته وزاره الفلاحه
ارتفاع حجم صادرات الفواكه والخضروات لتصل
الى مليونين وثلاثمائه الف طن خلال العام
الماضي بنمو بلغه عشره في المئه
في ظل موجه التضخم تتعالى اصوات احزاب
سياسيه ونقابات مهنيه ومواطنين بسطاء
تطالب الحكومه باجراءات اكثر فعاليه تخفف
من قهر الغلاء وتعيد الاسعار الى طبيعتها
المختاره العبلاويه الجزيره الرباط